This day will go down in the history of Parliament.
European
as the height of hypocrisy and hypocrisy
There are two ways to deal with illegal immigration.
1 method
this is the Polish method of the united right
namely
We block all forced relocation projects
For years we built a wall on the border
to stop illegal migration and even
we launched the action of special services
to
Detect and stop illegal activities
concerning 268 vision pieces
This is your second method.
You have invited millions of illegal migrants here
As it turned out
The German Government
is funding a boat with these illegal migrants
and the partner of one of the Bundestag MPs earns money on it
what are the effects
1 and 2 methods
The effects of our method
please.
According to your statistics
Poland should
najbezpieczniejszych countries of the European Union
and your effects
The effects of your method
Hundreds of killed people
exploding bombs
coups of war
Unusual number of rapes
including on little girls
Trauma for women for life
and this is your responsibility
Army needed on the streets of France and Sweden
because because of the usual ways can no longer cope
with immigration gangs
and you dare accuse Poland
It just hurts the contrast
Poland is your remorse
A monument proof of this
that it can be safe
and proof of how you betrayed your own people
and that's why you need Tosk
he has this contrast blur
But we will not allow it.
Poland will lead a rational Europe
and overthrow your migration system in a referendum
Other countries will follow us.